that's Gomez - welcome to another oculus
rift game today we're gonna play with
these we shower race or hydras basically
and I can stand up and I can use my arms
I'm gonna play a game that is optimized
for it and more or less you'll see what
I mean with that but anyway let's go oh
[Music]
look at my hat
I have two amazing this is actually kind
of cool with the rift but what the [ __ ]
is up with my hands
the game isn't really working that well
Dynamis oh [ __ ] I forgot how to snipe
damage Oh
hasta la vista de aragón chapter 2
that's this handle is Amy's pocket all
famous I betcha
but the
but Aldi you're doing oh no my god oh my
god that's fun
okay we're fine
damn it all right we fought that battle
Oh what are we doing over there yeah
[ __ ] oh yeah I forgot time to shotgun oh
god damn that's nasty
okay I think I'm reloading it visits out
of your shop man I got this [ __ ] bro
study ever wonder about it what you walk
bail double kill bail
triple tau rain when temple tau yes it's
probably the least luggage anyone I've
ever played chapter three last time that
is not how you snipe
god damn you what if I grab it with my
other hand yes don't miss klegg bench
bench this is our sniping Sweden
[ __ ] [ __ ] I swear to god yes oh
god damn it
okay let's say okay okay I got his hair
cut
I want that what
[Applause]
[Music]
yes okay am I
[Music]
poor the Italian I want to try to grab
it
Can I grab anything I have this hands
but I can't do it can you imagine the
poor growth you can touch tips and gaze
I guess there's only one option left
tell them when the box box Cal Cal Cal
[Music]
stomping Sam it's that [ __ ] kill
holiday with my box go goddamn it well
all right press that was a lot of fun I
have fun with it I got it I think I'm
gonna try another couple of games are
they I don't think I'm doing it right
but it's still hilarious for me of these
anyway they were like you enjoyed
watching it's a static room for a day
I'll see the next desperate subject
[Music]